bei der kleidung gibt es recht einfache
tipps die man die man sich zu herzen
nehmen kann das erste auf die
materialien achten was ziehe ich dann an
für materialien so was wie merinowolle
oder auch seide und kaschmir sind sehr
gut dafür geeignet die körpertemperatur
zu regulieren und daune isoliert gut und
dann ist der zweite faktor die kleidung
sollte möglichst locker sein das nicht
so ein luftpolster bilden können wenn
ich ganz enge kleidung anhaben
dann können sich keine luftschichten
bilden und die isolieren die speichern
die wärme unglaublich gut das heißt die
lockerer die kleidung sofern sie nicht
zu weit ist dann wird es einfach sperrt
luft überhaupt dazu halten desto desto
besser kann sie isolieren und dann
beweglichkeit in den kleinen stücken
behalten also wenn ich ganz steil für
dicke schuhe an habe kriege ich trotzdem
kalte füße wenn sich meine zehen nicht
ausreichend bewegen können weil dann die
durchblutung nicht ausreichend ist also
darauf achten dass sich alle körperteile
wirklich auch gut bewegen können und so
kann man mit den einfachen tipps
eigentlich auch aus seinem eigenen
kleiderschrank eine warme
wintergarderobe zaubern mehr nachrichten
und breaking news nur weil bild schau
dir hier das nächste video an und
vergiss nicht zu abonnieren